lorsqu'elles ont appris pendant leur
grossesse que leurs enfants étaient
porteurs de la trisomie 21
ces jeunes mamans ont été confrontés au
choix de l'avortement elles se sont
informés sur ce syndrome notamment
auprès de l'association du groupe pour
l'étude de l'insertion sociale des
porteurs de trisomie 21
le geste ensuite elles ont fait leur
choix
moi je suis entré en relation avec
l'association pendant ma grossesse j'ai
fait ma première échographie avec un
dépistage de fin d'août sur la trisomie
donc on a fait une amniocentèse au
moment de la confirmation du diagnostic
c'est l'hôpital qui m'a orienté vers
l'association et j'avais une décision à
prendre soin garder mon enfant et c'est
à ce moment là que je me suis rapproché
de l'association
on m'a proposé la muse synthèse les
fêtes donc bon après comme pour les
autres un jusqu'à la fin de ma grossesse
on m'a dit de me faire avorter
oui et je pouvais mettre un terme à ça
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à ce que j'accouche
c'est venu tout naturellement une fois
que j'avais rencontré les parents et les
autres enfants de l'association puisque
une fois qu'on les voit comme ils sont
là ont le choix est vite fait on se pose
pas la question finalement une fois
qu'on les voit on sait que bas et qu'ils
ont tous le droit d'être là donc voilà
une fois que j'ai rencontré les enfants
et les parents l'association ma décision
était prise au début mon mari lui
depuis quand on l'a appris il voulait
pas l'enlever moi j'avais un peu peur
parce que c'est pas pour la mais c'est
pour plus tard
si elles sont des maman épanouie elle se
trouve malgré tout face à des
difficultés
selon elle ce serait la société qui ne
serait pas adapté à la différence de
leurs enfants
je me suis dit que je voulais cette
enfant quoi qu'il arrive mais ce n'était
pas du tout une décision facile parce
que le lait mettre le corps médical et
puis la société vous met la pression
pour pour avorter parce que c'est un
enfant différent c'est pas un enfant de
normal
forcément ça va créer des problèmes et
voilà la société fait que sont appelés à
paraître on n'est pas totalement intégré
à 7
on se bat pour faire parce que on tourne
en fait j'avais su qu'ils stigmatisent
en fait c'est un enfant trisomique
donc en fait il faut qu'il aille là où
il ne peut pas faire ça moi
personnellement je ne l'aimais pas lucas
jeu il fera ce qu'il aura envie quand il
trouvera sa limite
j'accepterai en fait fin je veux qu'ils
aient l'export tout son potentiel en
fait cette pression sociale place les
mamans au coeur d'une contradiction
elles veulent le meilleur pour leurs
enfants mais ce meilleur ne se trouve
pas dans les standards de vie que la
société propose si c'était à refaire je
referais tout exactement de la même
façon demain si vous arrivez vous me
dites je t'échange eden contre un autre
enfant exactement le même sens un trio
me je n'en veux pas je veux idem comme
il l'est si c'était à refaire je
reprends comme ça mais pour autant c'est
paradoxal oui c'est contradictoire mais
je donnerai tout pour que mon enfant
soit comme les autres parce que pour lui
pas pour moi moi je le veux comme ça
mais pour lui j'aimerais que j'aimerais
qu'il fasse des études supérieures
j'aimerais qu'ils réalisent tous ses
rêves et je suis pas sûr que demain ils
puissent réaliser tous ses rêves
je suis pas sûr qu'il puisse passer son
permis par exemple je suis pas sûr
qu'ils puissent voyager tout seul je
suis pas sûr qu'il puisse avoir des
enfants j'en suis même certaine qu'il
n'y en aura pas je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils puissent construire une maison un
jour avoir une vie de femme ont ce genre
de choses
être comme tout le monde finalement mais
moi je le veux comme ça pour lui plus
tard pour apporter un soutien aux
familles et promouvoir l'inclusion des
personnes concernées par la trisomie 21
l'association le geste propose des
activités culturelles qui permet aux
parents et à leurs enfants de se
retrouver d'échanger encore dit beaucoup
de difficultés mais c'est avec d'autres
parents qu on peut trouver conseils quoi
je suis la maman de julia ya quinze ans
et je fais partie de l'association geist
21 depuis
sa naissance c'est à dire il avait à peu
près
deux mois quant à la naissance j'avais
demandé aux médias de rencontrer
d'autres personnes parce que moi je
voulais pas rester toute seule je vous
lis rencontre de parents et on a orienté
vers le geste et ben c'est ma deuxième
famille maintenant pratiquer ces
activités artistiques
c'est aussi un moyen pour les porteurs
de trisomie 21 de s'exprimer et dire
qu'ils existent en fait l'objectif c'est
de fait changer le regard des gens
ordinaires je suis agent du handicap
auparavant elle était un peu mise à
l'écart ce qui est vrai bon c'est vrai
que ça a beaucoup évolué ces vingt
dernières années avec notamment la loi
sur le handicap de 2005 qui prône une
infusion donc la société devient de plus
en plus inclusive mais y encore beaucoup
à faire je vais trouver quand ils font
du théâtre mais ils ont besoin non pas
d'être vu et de se montrer quoi dire
qu'on existe et regardez nous on est là
d'aussi onéguine ils vivent et on est
capable de faire des choses de belles
choses
j'aime bien la danse pourquoi pourquoi
j'aime bien la danse parce que j'aime
bien de un taux de bougies tout ça ça
peut plus ouais c'est quoi dans le
deuxième l'amour je dois me dire un
bouilleur jade le théâtre ça me plaît
bien
c'est pour eux c'est pour exprimer les
choses c'est pour se monter le handicap
et c'est parce qu'il adore être capables
les autres les activités artistiques
d'un véritable espace d'expression aux
personnes concernées par la trisomie 21
une expression qui participe à faire
évoluer la société
et pourquoi pas à fabriquer leurs
propres rêves
qui sait se taire